d'ici 2021 cette ancienne décharge
devenu une friche naturel pourrait
accueillir une ferme photovoltaïque de
20 hectares situé en bordure de la
départementale 190 42500 panneaux
solaires permettront de fournir de
l'électricité à l'ensemble des habitants
de triel sur seine
on a été il ya des années des années une
des premières communes à être une
commune verte
on a toujours continué dans cet esprit a
travaillé à faire du tri sélectif est
donc une panneau solaire l'énergie
renouvelable c'est aussi notre notre
souci il y a dix ans le projet avait été
abandonné en raison de l'instabilité du
sol
une enquête publique a été lancée au
début du mois d'avril
objectif permettre aux habitants d'en
savoir plus sur cette ferme
photovoltaïque c'est bien c'est pour
l'écologie c'est pour le climat donc
c'est bien que des avantages
on va remplacer des déchets par quelque
chose de favorable à la à la nature dans
le contexte actuel c'est pas quand même
pas une mauvaise idée plutôt qu'une
décharge
enfin sur une décharge on pourra rien
faire donc un donc change tout c'est une
bonne solution aujourd'hui une
alternative écologique intéressante pour
la société urbasolar a été choisi pour
aménager ce parc solaire estimé à 18
mégawatts
en plus d'être une zone inconstructible
le site possède également un autre
intérêt on a un poste de transformation
en f1 proximité donc le raccordement
il faudra tirer du cap entre 3 km vers
ça c'est un avantage pour nos dans les
prochaines semaines le dossier sera
entre les mains de la creux la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
c'est cet organisme indépendant qui est
chargé de valider ou non le projet
verdict aux alentours du mois de
septembre